liste des solutions concrètes pour
sortir de la crise entre l'ukraine et la
russie chez emmanuel macron optimistes
mais prudents après son marathon
diplomatique après la russie hier le
président français a été reçu à kiev
aujourd'hui la france veut relancer les
accords de minsk conclure en 2015 il y
aura d'ailleurs une première rencontre
des conseillers russes ukrainiens
français et allemands jeudi à berlin
le 26 janvier dernier les quatre pays
ont réaffirmé leur engagement à mettre
en oeuvre les accords de minsk qui ont
vocation à rendre l'ukraine son
intégrité territoriale
et qui trace le chemin vers la paix
hier avec le président poutine j'ai
longuement évoquée évidemment ce sujet
et il s'est lui-même ré engagé à
respecter les accords
conformément aux accords conclus lors du
sommet de paris en décembre 2019 nous
attendons à pouvoir tenir très
prochainement les négociations entre les
dirigeants des pays les formats noir
la première réunion a été très réussie
nous attendons avec impatience une
deuxième réunion dans les prochains
jours
nous espérons que la réunion du 26
janvier et les futures discussions à
berlin nous rapprocherons de la tenue du
sommet du format nantes
et avec mon bruno daroux bonjour brunoh
bonjour julien les accords de minsk
d'abord c'est quoi alors les accords de
minsk ont été et comment dire ont été
faits écrit rédigé souffler en deux fois
en deux occasions uminski minsk de 2014
2015 donc essentiellement en fait il
s'agit côté ukrainien de garantir le
fait que le don de bassar est un
territoire ukrainien donc l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine soit
sauvegardée mais en échange l'ukraine
s'est engagé à accorder un statut
spécial au don de vastes peuplée
majoritairement de russophones et du
coup a procédé à une modification de sa
constitution pour reconnaître ce statut
spécial seulement pour le moment
l'ukraine n'a rien fait pourquoi pascal
nique avant de faire ça il faut que tous
les groupes armés les pro russes et
séparatistes pro russes et aussi les
quelques russes qui s'y trouvent tous
les hommes armés soit parti du camp de
base ce qui selon l'ukraine n'est pas le
cas et les négociations achoppent depuis
maintenant quelques années sur ce point
apprécié donc là emmanuel macron
évidemment son homologue ukrainien a dit
ce qu'ils sont prêts à relancer ces
accords de minsk vladimir poutine
également l'a dit après il faut voir
concrètement il y aura effectivement
cette réunion des conseillers des quatre
pays avec l'allemagne aussi qui est
partie prenante une deuxième réunion
donc aura lieu jeudi et le président
ukrainien espère même que très vite les
dirigeants pourront se parler peut-être
lors d'un sommet les quatre dirigeants
donc ukrainien russe français allemand
pour essayer de débloquer 5 heures de
mise alors il faut bien comprendre que
ce problème des accords de minsk et du
don de base il est un peu périphériques
par rapport à la menace essentielle que
représentent les troupes russes aux
frontières mais si un déblocage sur les
accords de minsk c'est un peu ça le
calcul des manuels macro ça ça
engrangerait si vous voulez un cercle
vertueux qui fait que peut-être ça
permettrait d'apaiser par ailleurs les
autres tensions et l'autre partie du
problème qui vient de l'otan avec
l'adhésion éventuelle de l'ukraine à
l'alliance transatlantique n'y a pas eu
d'avancée là sur ce point non il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas eu encore d'avancé
parce que c'est quand même ça le point
principal de blocage l'explication
principale de la crise c'est que pour
les russes et bien l'otan ne cesse de
grappiller dans ces zones d'affluence et
la l'ukraine s'est un peu trop quoi il
ya eu les pays baltes la pologne la
roumanie la hongrie mais là l'ukraine ça
c'est pas possible c'est une ligne rouge
pour moscou et donc moscou demande que
si on veut sortir de la crise actuelle
est bien l'otan s'engage à ne pas
s'élargir notamment à l'ukraine donc
pour l'otan cette île c'est inacceptable
donc on bute toujours là dessus même si
on sent qu'il ya des débuts de
négociations dont on connaît pas encore
bien les contours mais qui pourraient
faire en sorte que les deux parties
s'engagent à ce qu'il n'y ait pas des
moyens militaires très importants
déployés en ukraine alors ça pourrait
aboutir dès defacto si vous voulez à une
forme de neutralité de l'ukraine qui
ferait que l'ukraine n'aurait pas
demandé son adhésion à l'otan l'otan
n'aurait pas la réclame et moscou
n'aurait pas à se plaindre de cette
demande d'adhésion et du coup ça fait
que la la crise seraient apaisés moscou
retirer ses troupes de la frontière
ukrainienne bon on en est pas encore là
mais on sent que ça bouge un petit peu
et puis l'autre élément un peu positif
c'est que l'annuaire poutine a dit qu'il
était assez intéressé par les
propositions des manuels macron sur des
questions jugées secondaires par les
russes mais quand même importante sur
les questions de sécurité de déploiement
de missiles sur l'ensemble du continent
européen pour qu'il y ait plus de
transparence de part et d'autre qu'on
essaie de réduire le déploiement des
missiles notamment à courte et moyenne
portée merci